this is newly released body cam footage
of the response to the attack at robb
elementary school in uvalde
nearly 400 officers were called to the
school but they failed to take any
action for more than an hour
the shooter killed 19 students and two
teachers before he was confronted by
by police and killed mike hanna reports
if there's only one thing that i can
tell you is
there were multiple systemic failures
the three members of the bipartisan
texas house committee held a news
conference to discuss the report
it comes just a few days after this new
security camera footage was released
the sounds of the children screaming are
edited out but it shows local police
arriving two minutes after the shooting
started
a few approach the classroom door but
then retreat back down the corridor
after shots are fired
the report is adamant that during this
time officers at a federal or state
level should have taken over control
from the school police chief pete
arredondo who was supposedly in charge
at the school
today teredondo has taken much of the
blame but sunday's report says
responsibility for the lack of action
should be shared by some of the 376 law
enforcement officers who had arrived as
well as their superiors at a command
level at a minimum
there is multiple opportunities
depending on the relative training and
experience of law enforcement officers
to at least ask more questions or offer
their guidance to try to remedy the
chaotic situation and make sure there is
effective overall command there was a
lack of effective overall command that
day
the report also found the school's
safety protocols fell far short numerous
doors were left unlocked which allowed
the gunman easy access to the classrooms
in a wider context the legislators also
found that these issues were not unique
to the ross elementary school where the
shooting happened
that protocols not observed created a
dangerous sense of false security let me
tell you the people of uvalde before
this
they felt it couldn't happen here
they felt that that's the false sense of
security i worry about i think some of
the same systems
that we found here that failed that day
are across the entire state and country
the report is dedicated to the 21
victims of the shooting and was given to
family and friends at a meeting an hour
before its public release
a report that drove home the tragic fact
that law enforcement officials waited
for some 75 minutes while gunfire
continued
before a group of border patrol guards
to fight orders on the scene and rushed
in to kill the gunman
mike hannah al-jazeera washington